the security situation at kabul airport
is again worsening days before the u.s
and its allies pull out on august 31st
tens of thousands of people have been
gathering their desperately hoping to
leave afghanistan washington is now
telling us citizens gathered at the
airport's entrances to leave immediately
governments are increasingly worried
about a terror attack at the airport
poland and belgium have already
announced they're ending their
evacuation flights
with time running out to evacuate people
these are among the final flights out of
the afghan capital those who are able to
leave know they may never see their
homeland again
i can't explain it with the words
and i am not sure my tears will be able
to explain it
it was always so hard and it is so so
hard
heartbreak and yet a luxury for those
able to flee fleeing may not be an
option this time next week the americans
say they will leave afghanistan at the
end of the month european allies will
follow suit but u.s cargo jets may soon
not be carrying afghans
so in those last couple of days
we will begin to prioritize
military capabilities and military
resources to to move out uh that doesn't
mean that um
that if if you're your evacuee and and
uh
and you need to get out that we're just
then we're not gonna try to get you out
not all who want to leave will be able
to the taliban say foreigners can go but
citizens cannot standing knee deep in
sewage water they plead with soldiers
guarding the airport knowing time is
running out just getting here was a near
impossible task but this may be where
their difficult journey ends
for people who are outside of
afghanistan 31st august is just a date
but for us it's like whether you will go
or you will stay forever
stay and live under a taliban afghans
know all too well
or try to escape
with little chance of returning
matt zeller joins me now from washington
dc he's with the association of wartime
allies and he's also a veteran of the
war in afghanistan welcome to dw
your association helps interpreters and
others who have supported the us in
afghanistan can they all be evacuated in
time before joe biden's deadline
no
by our estimation uh we're going to
leave upwards of 175 000 people behind
and
what should the united states do with
those people
we made them a fundamental promise
that in their moment of need in their
darkest hour if they were in duress we
would take them with us
we should be keeping that promise we
should not be allowing the taliban to
dictate terms to us
we are still the most powerful military
on the planet
and for once we ought to use it for a
sole purpose of good
i i have to tell you as a veteran and as
an american i'm
deeply deeply disappointed in my
government and my president
for letting the taliban dictate the
terms of this withdrawal
now there must be hundreds of individual
stories uh
of people who are trying to get out give
us a picture of what it's like for those
who are waiting for evacuation right now
so if you're an afghan right now
you have about a day a day left to get
to the airport by some means and it that
is a seemingly impossible task now
the taliban have surged their special
operations troops into kabul they're
called the haqqani taliban they look
like u.s special operations soldiers
with their uniforms and american-made
equipment and gear
they are now responsible for the
security around the airport they are
preventing any afghan passport holder
from getting to the airport by whatever
violent means is necessary the only
people who are allowed through are
foreign passport holders
uh we have tried desperately to get our
afghan wartime allies all of whom only
hold afghan passports many of whom hold
valid u.s visas to the airport they have
been promised flights and they simply
cannot get through on social media
you've seen i'm sure the the horrific
scenes of the the human
squalored conditions outside of the
gates you know there's no working
toilets people have been in line for
days the the temperatures are hot humid
and oppressive there's no food there's
no water the taliban go through the
crowd and beat people indiscriminately
and often fire into the air on the
ground to try to to move the crowd along
what you're now going to see however
is
the lack of american and allied soldiers
on the other sides of those walls
they're going to begin being replaced by
taliban soldiers manning the gates at
the airport and so while afghans have
this whole time had at least maybe an
allied
you know nato allied member that they
could wave down the italians were
brilliant they told all of their
evacuees to tie red scarves or red
pieces of fabric around their wrists and
hold it up and and that way an italian
service member know that that was
somebody that they needed to evacuate
personally if you could get in sight
with them they often could come and get
you that's going to end the taliban said
in their press conference yesterday no
afghan is allowed to leave afghanistan
and sharia law is coming mat seller
thank you so so much for your insights
war veteran and with the association of
wartime allies matt zeller thank you